leisten können dafür gibt es
spezialisierte stiftungen wir haben eine
familie bei der wohnungssuche begleitet
dieser wohnblock in einem zürcher
aussenquartier seit einem halben jahr
das zuhause von familie ja doch bald
schon muss sie wieder rausziehen
das gebäude wird abgebrochen wir waren
sehr besorgt weil in eine wohnung zu
finden
vor neun jahren flüchtete aus magazine
aus eritrea in die schweiz vor
zweieinhalb jahren konnte seine frau
nina endlich nachkommen
sie lernt zwar intensiv deutsch auch das
haushaltseinkommen bestreitet er allein
als schneider
es liegt deshalb unter den durchschnitts
bedarf einer vierköpfigen familie in der
schweiz lebenswertes wohnen für alle
eine der fragen die marie glas am morgen
an einer veranstaltung der eth aufwirft
sie leitet das wohn führende hochschule
in den städten wo wohnraum immer
knapperen oder sagen wir so die
verteilung nicht perfekt ist es gäbe
vielleicht günstigen wohnraum aber es
nicht nicht richtig verteilt werden
sozial benachteiligte menschen an die
ränder verdrängt oder über die
stadtgrenze hinaus
das halte ich für bedenkenswert warum
weil eine stadt davon lebt dass sie
durch wichtig wohnraum für alle bieten
sollte
von dieser vielfalt auch leben
hilfe bietet dem ziel die zürcher
stiftung ist eine von mehreren
hierzulande die bezahlbaren wohnraum
suchen
sie unterstützt bei bewerbung vermittelt
zwischen verwaltungen und
wohnungssuchenden all das große plus ist
mit übernahme solidarhaftung da hoffe
ich dass mir aus imitierter im vertrag
drin sind und dort menschen
verantwortlich anträgen domizil erhält
viel mehr anfragen als die wohnungen
vermitteln kann
von den 140 pro jahr geht nun eine
familie jaffé heute bekommt zur
integration am neuen ort eine
genossenschaft
sie wissen dass eine genossenschaft ich
erkläre es ist mir eine familie die idee
ist
sie sind nicht nur mieter sondern auch
verwalter sehe das wie machen sie die
urteilsbildung sie den waschplatz über
solche regeln und gebräuche aufzuklären
gehört zum leistungsauftrag so wirkt das
zukünftige zusammenleben weniger
konfliktpotenzial ist es wichtig dass
sie hier entsteht in den nächsten jahren
ein neues klavier green city es liegt
fast mitten in zürich dank domizil
können die jungs bald an diese begehrte
lage ziehen
[Musik]
sie haben ihr spezielles programm auch
kulturelle unterschiede werden
aufgenommen
wie hilft genauso beim einleben wie die
beherrschung der technischen gerät für
yasin es bietet der umzug die chance
sich weiter zu integrieren
die frage wie man bedürftigen egal
welcher herkunft zugang zu besserem
wohnraum verschafft ist gesellschaftlich
relevant ein angemessener wohnraum
ermöglicht lebensqualität und ermöglicht
auch teilhabe an der gesellschaft ich
kann mich total entwickeln ich kann
beziehungen eingehen ich kann ich kann
arbeiten und wohnen verknüpfen ich kann
mein soziales leben mit meinem
arbeitsleben verknüpfen oder es tränen
wenn ich wenig bietet die möglichkeit
meine existenz sicherten würdig und und
gesund zu leben
es geht uns alle an
nur während zufriedenstellen den
verhältnissen lebt kann sich als mensch
konstruktiv einbringen in die
gesellschaft generation ist das
christkind und wirst du